When we are reasoning about a program, our reasoning follows these dependencies.
In this case, if we want to know where C comes from or where quote comes from,
we follow the dependencies to the specific locations, and we can do so again.
If we are up here, for instance,
and we want to know where C comes from, well, C comes from S,
and S comes from up here.
S first goes down here, then defines C, and then C is being checked.
Likewise, if we want to know where quote comes from,
quote comes from this statement.
So we see again, here quote is being written, here quote is being read.
So this statement depends on itself,
and quote, again, can either come from this location,
or it can come from the original assignment.
It is precisely along these relationships
that we structure our reasoning.
Where does this value come from, and where was it set?
If we take a look at this statement, however,
we will quickly find that data dependencies are not enough
because the value of quote in here may depend on the earlier value of quote,
but we also need to take into account
that this statement had to be executed in the first place.
In order to be executed, it depends on earlier conditions.
This is the concept of control dependency.
If there is some statement which controls whether the statement B is executed or not,
then B is being control dependent on that very statement.
In our example up here, for instance,
the condition in A controls whether statement B is executed or not.
Therefore, B is control dependent on A.
Again, such dependencies guide our reasoning.
We find that B was executed,
and we want to know why it was executed, after all.
In order to figure out why it was executed,
we follow the control dependencies.
Here is a quiz.
Which other statement does B control depend upon?
Is this for C in S?
Is this the first if statement?
Is this the first elif statement?
Or is this the last elif statement?
Check all that apply.